So, here, once again, is our graph of the volume of a box versus the length of
the cut that we put in it, to be able to fold the sides up. And clearly, the one
that we have here is the restricted domain version, the one that Athena wanted,
because of the real life situation that she was using this in conjunction with.
However, let's take a second to look at the equation for this function. We had A
of x so you go to 7 minus 2X times 5 minus 2X times x. And you'll remember
earlier on, I multiplied all of these out. And when we do this all of this
multiplication out, we get a different form, for expressing this function, 4x
cubed minus 24x squared plus 35x. And the reason I wanted multiplication out
right now, so I think you might notice, this equation is pretty different from
anything else that we've grasped so far in the course. In particular, we have an
exponent of 3 in our function. What on earth does a graph that has a third
degree term in it look like? Well, why don't we get rid of these domain
restrictions briefly and zoom out, and look at the entire graph that this is
part of. So, here's the full version of our function without any domain
restrictions. Multiply it out. The function, itself, is 4x cubed minus 24x
squared plus 35x. This is a totally different equation than anything we've dealt
with before, graphically, at least, though we did see expressions that look like
this early on in the course. Because this function has a different degree than
other functions we've dealt with, it's going to have different graphical
properties as well. Now, I've labeled a few different special points on the
graph or points that may potentially be special. And I'd like you to help
identify what they are. So, in each of the purple boxes over here, to complete
the statements, I'd like you to fill in letters that go with these different
points. And there's this blue one right here, this, I'd like to be a number that
you just type in. So basically, I'm asking you which points are the x-intercept
and how many are there? Where the function changes from increasing to
decreasing, and when it changes from decreasing to increasing.